Allora noi andiamo a curve abbiamo
questo Chalet pazzesco sulle piste
gigante abbiamo invitato tutta la clan
della clan dell'altra società poi 26
febbraio andiamo alle Seychelles ne
abbiamo portato questo viaggio esclusivo
calcolo che abbiamo un maggiordomo
ciascuno veramente uno scettiglia e
quanti ti chiedo 55 euro beh tesoro Sei
carina se si fatica ma sei un po' cara
fattilo dire ma fammi un riscontro Scusa
eh Sai cosa facciamo Io adesso ti mando
un po' di eh di signore di un certo
livello gente che vuoi spendere gente
che spende bene Eh tu fai sconto Ciao
Katia Guarda è successo un casino Eh sì
abbiamo un appuntamento tra 40 minuti
però cavolo è successo un delirio Poi ti
spiego Ti dico solo che sono in ospedale
Quindi se riuscissi a spostarmi
l'appuntamento Non lo so più verso
Natale sei piena eh
non riesci proprio
E vabbè dai allora niente allora cerco
dai allora ci vediamo tra poco va bene
Ciao ciao
buona anche fare shopping in pace però
allora Katia avevo pensato di farvi un
po' diverse dal solito un po' più
originali giusto perché siamo durante le
feste per Natale volevo farle tipo rosse
Ok poi per Capodanno invece argentate ma
non argentate normali argentate coi
brillantini ci stanno [ __ ]